or the mask we are joined now by former
CDC director that's dr. Tom Frieden he
is a president and CEO of the initiative
resolve to save lives which works to
prevent epidemics good morning to you
dr. Frieden I want to start with
president Trump's remarks over the
weekend that 99% of the cases are
harmless that's really hard to take
especially today following the death of
Nick Cordero's 41 walked into the
emergency room they were thinking it's
pneumonia of course we all know he did
not make it out so what did you think
when you heard that no thanks for asking
thanks for covering this I think part of
the challenge here is that we've lost
the nuance some people are saying this
is a hoax it's fake it's not serious
other people may be saying it's the
worst thing in the world if the zombie
apocalypse is neither this is a terrible
pandemic it has killed 130,000 Americans
it has sickened many many more and we
don't yet know what the long-term
complications of some of that illness is
but it is true that 99% of the people
who get it will survive we need a more
nuanced approach right now the virus has
the upper hand throughout much of
America most of America we can regain
the upper hand if we work together if we
work together we can get our kids back
to school in the fall we can restart our
economy and we can prevent deaths but
we'll only do that by coming together to
stop the bars it's not going to stop on
its own we have to stop it and we do
that through the three WS we're a mask
wash your hands
watch your distance and by strategic
testing this focus on the number of
tests is totally misguided what we need
to be asking yeah that's right things
being done yes go that's what I want to
get into dr. Frieden a testing because
the president is blaming the surge on
the increase in testing does he have a
point although is true were testing were
we're finding a whole lot more and so it
is absolutely clear this is a real
increase you don't have to tell the
doctors and the emergency rooms who are
dealing with tons of patients
now throughout the south and south
southeast Southwest of the US that this
is real it's real now the fact is we're
also seeing this more in younger adults
222 four-year-old 40 year olds it was a
mistake to open bars early and we're
paying for that mistake but there are
things that everyone can do to quiet
this down if you're a young adult
remember you don't want to have a severe
illness or death of an older relative on
your conscious for the rest of your life
everyone who's exposed needs to
quarantine everyone who's within six
feet of other people needs to wear a
mask there's a lot of things we can do
and there's no one perfect answer it's a
comprehensive all of society response
you know Gayle we are an outlier
countries all over the world in Africa
in Asia in Europe
yeah controlling the virus it's not easy
but we're not yeah but there's another
interesting development it's being
reported that scientists are asking the
World Health Organization to update the
virus update us on how the virus is
spread is there new information about
that or new concerns about how the virus
is spread we're still not sure of some
of the details and that's one of the
reasons we need to do those detailed
investigations of every case a great
epidemic response learns constantly what
the debate is among scientists is how
common is what's called aerosol
transmission and that means that fine
particles stay in the air for an hour or
two we know it happens own it happens in
health care facilities when you do
certain procedures it happens when
choirs sing it spews particles out there
that can infect a lot of people it also
is true that there is spread from
contaminated surfaces but for all of
those things wearing a mask an think a
really big difference that's why
everyone needs to wear a mask when there
we can six feet of other people all
right I just wish people would listen to
the scientists and you're right most
people recover from this kovat via kovat
19 but if you're one of the rare people
that don't recover that's little
consolation when you see the figures
thank you dr. Thomas Frieden we
appreciate your time